yippy chimera lovers it's Jan here after
the release of the spectacular Avengers
infinity war trailer we finally got a
better look at what the Avengers will be
facing up to when Thanos and his Black
Order invade the earth and now some
amazing descriptions from infinity war
LEGO sets have leaked that may reveal
what we can expect from six key action
scenes in the movie
my superhero giveaway is also running on
this video for all my subscribers and
I'll have full details on that later in
the video and just before I go any
further obviously I'm talking potential
spoilers and speculation for the
upcoming Avengers infinity war movie
plus previous Marvel films so if you
prefer you can tap in the top right to
watch my breakdown of the official
trailer instead let's get into the
details of these six key scenes which
come from the release of Lego set
descriptions published on a toy site
called EXO force I'm going to start with
a particularly interesting set called
the search for Thor's weapon which
includes minifigures for Thor Rocket
Raccoon and Groot and which also
mentions an unknown infinity stone the
set describes the quest where Thor goes
off with rocket and Groot in search of a
new weapon now that he no longer has
Mjolnir curiously this description fits
in with a piece of official concept art
that Marvel released in a very early
Infinity Ward here's a video of Thor
wielding what looks like an axe and
rocket firing alongside him the lego set
description also states that Thor
travels to a red planet called need of
alia one of the nine realms this planet
which is inhabited by dwarves is
actually where Mjolnir was originally
forged in the words of Odin in the heart
of a dying star the leaked description
mentions that Thor uses space forges
which I think explains this mysterious
shot of Thor in the trailer where he's
straining to operate or control some
kind of machine an unspecified infinity
stone is also mentioned in the
description as well as using energy to
create a new axe the axe referred to
here is most likely yarn beyond a weapon
forged by dwarves and used by Thor
before Mjolnir the axe is incredibly
sharp with the power to slice through
almost anything and it's also virtually
indestructible based on the description
it also sounds like an infinity stone
might be involved in the creation of
Thor's new weapon and I think this could
be the reality stone which we last saw
given to the collector at the end of
Thor the dark world we know from the
Infinity Ward
raela that thanos already has the power
stone and the space stone that his Black
Order is extracting the mind stone from
vision and that dr. strange has the time
stone and at the moment I feel that the
soul stone is probably going to be in
Wakanda
that leaves the reality stone which was
actually mentioned in some recently
leaked infinity war footage where Thanos
interrogate the collector about an
infinity stone which tan Elliott even
claims he sold to someone if what the
collector says is true then I wonder
whether the person who sold it to might
be Peter Dinklage's character who then
takes it to the Dwarven home need of
alia the next set is based back on earth
with many figures of Bruce Banner Falcon
and Proxima midnight plus the soul stone
it describes a scene where Proxima
midnight has captured a tower and starts
firing on a Hulk Buster Bruce Banner
this seems to confirm my theory from my
trailer breakdown video that it's not
actually Tony Stark we see in the
Hulkbuster armor in the infinity war
trailer a six-limbed enemy is also
mentioned in the description which means
that the four armed two-legged outriders
that the black order commands will also
be involved in this scene finally the
set description orders Falcon to dive
down and capture the soul stone which
seems to confirm the final stone is
being kept in Wakanda
given that's where the trailer shows a
hook Buster the epic battle in Wakanda
which we saw teased in the trailer also
features in another set that includes
Captain America Black Widow and an army
of outriders as well as a space stone
the set description talks about Captain
America and Black Widow helping in the
defense of Wakanda against the invading
outriders interestingly it mentions that
cap uses his shield in the battle which
confirms we will be seeing cap back with
some kind of shield as we also heard
Black Panther say in the trailer we know
that Thanos will be after the time stone
which at the end of Doctor Strange was
being stored in strangers sanctum
sanctorum this Lego set description
suggests that we'll see spider-man and
Iron Man join with Doctor Strange to
fend off two of thanasis Black Order
cull obsidian and ebony more during
their attack on the New York sanctum the
fifth set reveals a potentially
intriguing moment involving Black Order
member Corvus glaive
vision black panther and sherée it
describes a scene where Corvus glaive is
launching an attack
and black panther then enters a battle
while Shuri attempts to remove the mine
stone from vision now this seems
somewhat at odds with the scene of
Corvus glaive attacking visions mine
stone with the tip of his blade in the
trailer so this could be a moment before
then where Shuri is trying to remove the
Infinity stone before Corvus glaive gets
hold of it alternatively it might be
that Cherie is trying to remove it
because vision has fallen under the
control of the black order when Corvus
glaive touched his mine stone in this
moment in the trailer and the final Lego
set describes what it calls sanest the
last battle and has Iron Man's star-lord
and Gamora going up against the mad
Titan the scene appears to take place in
space with Thanos using a huge sword to
defend himself the sword Thanos uses
sounds like it might be a little nod to
the infinity sword which appeared on the
animated Super Hero Squad show or
possibly syrtis Twilight sword which we
already saw in Thor Ragnarok okay so
those are the six leaked Lego set and
scene descriptions but before we assume
that these are a hundred percent
guaranteed to happen in the movie we
need to bear in mind that these are toy
sets which may be playing fast and loose
with aspects of the story in the film
toy sets have sometimes switched
characters around for example for
Avengers age of Ultron a toy was
released of Captain America on the
motorbike that gets launched from the
Avengers Quinn jet whereas in the movie
it was Black Widow who was on that
motorbike even if they aren't all
accurate though some of these Lego set
descriptions do seem to match up with
the snippets we've seen in the first
infinity war trailer and give us a bit
of a better understanding of what might
be going on so what do you think about
these potential action scenes for
Avengers infinity war and what are you
most looking forward to seeing in the
movie let me know your thoughts and
theories in the comments below also be
sure to subscribe and comment to end my
Avengers infinity war giveaway for a
chance to win a very cool Marvel Funko
pop and if you liked this do hit that
thumbs up button and tap the screen for
more of my Marvel theories and infinity
war videos thanks for watching and see
you next time
you PK movie lovers
you